foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote webinar titled toward Universal
coronavirus vaccines from concept to
clinic this webinar is part of the
coronavirus virtual event series the
seventh in the series and I'm Susie
Valdez of labridge and I will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots so let's get started before we
begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find that live chat
located on the right of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
on the help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby
I now present today's speaker Dr Kavon
majered Dr majered is the founding
director of the emerging infectious
disease Branch at the Walter Reed Army
Institute of research and associate
professor of medicine at the uniformed
service University Dr majira leads the
U.S Army's development of a vaccine
against covid-19 co-leads all of the
rares covid-19 response efforts and
serves as a member of operation warp
speed Dr majered is also an advisory
member of the World Health
organization's strategic Advisory Group
of experts immunization working group on
covid-19 vaccines and vaccination for
complete biography of our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the left of
your screen Dr majered welcome you may
now begin your presentation
thanks very much Susie for that uh kind
introduction and thank you to labroots
and the organizers for giving me the
opportunity to speak to you today
um as Susie mentioned uh I'll be talking
about a broadly uh active approach
towards
coronaviruses but I've narrowed it a
little bit to
um a subset of coronavirus the sars-like
viruses or cervical viruses
and I'll talk about uh how we took an
approach early on
from the first day that the sequences
were published of this novel coronavirus
towards the development of a broadly
immunogenic nanoparticle platform that
really anticipates
um and provides protection against the
evolving strains and emerging species of
coronaviruses
this is just to say that these opinions
are
um that are expressed in this
presentation or that of my own
um that they do not necessarily
represent those of my employer which is
the Department of Defense and that I
don't have any relevant conflicts or
disclosures to report
I like to start with acknowledging the
contributors and collaborators to the
work that I'll be showing you today
it takes a lot of folks to do research
about takes a lot of folks to do vaccine
development
first and foremost my own program and
all the folks in my team and
particularly Dr Gordon Joyce's um
my co-eventor on the vaccine that I'll
be talking about today as well as a
number of collaborators within our
Institute the Wall Street Army Institute
of research
others across the U.S federal government
as well as collaborators in Academia
industry
and this is a picture of our our uh just
a subset of our group on a night summer
day uh in the middle of the pandemic
when we could we were
um vaccinated the first time around and
could get outside and and take off some
masks for a picture but
um uh we're a much larger group than
this now but we really started out sort
of as a kind of a little Garage Band
um working on the development of this
vaccine and one of our folks the third
person not from the left one of our
scientists in the lab she's a
illustrator and so she's been uh
documenting The Many Adventures of our
vaccine
um in the in the context of uh some
animations that hopefully will make a a
graphic novel into
so
I thought it would be appropriate to
start out with a quote
um and a quote that reflects the
tendency of the public health and the
scientific communities
after
or as an epidemic or pandemic is waning
I've been involved with a number of
Public Health emergencies over the past
10 years
um
coronavirus zika virus
H1N1 and Ebola
and each time there's this introspection
that takes place in which we ask
ourselves how we can do better the next
time around
and it tends to Veer into the direction
of trying to predict what happens next
rather than trying to
um take stock in the gaps that we've we
had and and
um and Shore up those gaps for the next
pandemic and so one of my colleagues who
is really one of the fathers of of
emerging infectious diseases was the
founder of something called ProMed which
provides a lot of very important
surveillance information it was one of
the first that
um that reported this new
strange respiratory disease in southern
China in December and his name is
Stephen Morrison he uh
uh made me aware of a quote that I was
previously unaware of and I'm a big
sci-fi guy I love Ray Bradbury but I was
not aware of this Ray Bradbury quote
from 1982.
and when she said people asked me to
predict the future when all I want to do
is prevent it and I think that
uh captures uh where I want to go with
this presentation what I've tried to
imbue my program uh with the kind of
philosophy that guides the kind of
products that we develop
uh Broad
platforms for vaccines Therapeutics and
Diagnostics that are anticipating the
next potential epidemics and pandemics
so uh if you go back to 2014 2016
um when there was a huge outbreak the
largest outbreak at that time of Ebola
in West Africa
um what we saw was that Ebola had been
discovered in 1976 and over the course
of the next
uh 40 years essentially there are
multiple other outbreaks in central
Africa
um and they were relatively small
relatively self-limited they burned
themselves out they were devastating to
the communities they affected but they
were relatively contained
and I think it was always a sort of a
failure of imagination on the part of
the research and public health
communities that this could potentially
blow up in a much denser more populated
region
and that's exactly what happened in West
Africa 2014.
and so we were able to get a vaccine for
Ebola
um but not until after 11
000 12 000 individuals had perished
um and the Really
um
difficult thing to to to deal with is
that this vaccine's first vaccine that
was licensed for Ebola had been on
the shelves for about 15 years had been
tested in multiple animal models but no
one
really felt there was a need to invest
in the clinical trial and so when this
huge outbreak occurred we were already
behind the curve and literally behind
the epidemic curve we were able to get
some efficacy data and this is a lot of
the work that I did when I was at the
who for a year in 2015. uh in the
context of modified clinical trials but
um you know had we had some of that
clinical information earlier uh we could
have really
um deployed this vaccine almost
immediately in the context of the
outbreak
um so that's I think a lesson that needs
to be made in terms of doing as much as
we can before the outbreaks occur and
even in the context of the current
pandemic we had been working when I was
at the National Institutes of Health on
coronaviruses for about eight years
prior and
um we were lucky that we were working on
that because that led to a lot of the
quick
and Rapid development of some of these
vaccines for covid-19 but again
for the millions that perished the tens
of millions or hundreds of millions are
infected before the vaccines were
available and in many ways in a lot of
places they're still not uh fully
accessible and despite them being
developed and authorized within here
that still was too late for for too many
and some people are not always swayed by
the the argument of of Public Health and
and and saving lives so we also
um tried to make the arguments
um in terms of financial impact and and
economic costs as well
um if we took look at the center of the
screen
MERS Middle East Respiratory Syndrome
Coronavirus uh which is one of those
chronoviruses that is also highly fatal
which are probably the most fatal of the
coronaviruses that we know but does not
transmit well
fortunately
despite that it infected about it's uh
um an affected only 186 individuals in
South Korea in 2015.
it um killed about 20 percent of those
and yet it caused a nine billion dollar
economic loss for the South Korean
economy contracted the economy that year
by about two percent
just from 160 cases and so
you know we had been trying to make
these sorts of arguments before the
pandemic and we saw another pandemic uh
or another epidemic could cause you know
billions of dollars well the estimated
impact is probably going to be upwards
of 80 trillion dollars uh when this
pandemic is finally open and so
what should we do uh to prepare there
have been a lot of
uh initiatives
and particularly since the Ebola
outbreak of West Africa in 2014-16
to focus on developing vaccines for
those pathogens that may likely cause
pandemics or huge epidemics in the
future
and there's all these different lists
that have been developed and that's one
of the areas that I was talking about in
terms of trying to predict what's coming
next
and so if you look at
um and I'll I'll show this in a couple
of slides but if you look at how the
pandemics are
uh emerging infectious diseases have
progressed over the past Century or so
there's a pattern that emerges
um and
um
there is a
can you see my size by the way
okay I'm just assuming you cancel my
advice and so
I'm sorry there was a
change here so
I can't see if it's I have a preview
okay there you go
um so
here if we're focusing on the uh the few
uh that may likely uh cause pandemics in
the future which ones do we focus on
well we could go back to the ones that
have caused outbreaks in the past
um and say well
um let's focus on those but I think we
need to focus we it doesn't really we're
sort of fighting the wars of the past
and rather than fighting the wars of the
future
um and
this comes down to I think a basic
concept
that we keep seeing the same things over
and over again
but we we it feels like we're seeing
them for the first time and what I mean
by that is that if you saw if you go
just to coronaviruses we had SARS in
2002 merge in 2012. it was very likely
that we were going to see another highly
pathogenic coronavirus because in the
interim between SARS and Mars there were
two other human coronaviruses that were
identified
um that caused much milder illness and
more of a common cold but there was an
accelerating emergence or accelerating
discovery of these coronaviruses and
um it wasn't shouldn't have been
surprised in that another coronavirus
emerged now the scope and the extent to
which it affected Global populations was
a bit of a surprise but the fact that we
saw another one was really not much of a
surprise at all
so
here's my point if you look at the
number of viruses of relevance to human
populations and human disease that have
been discovered
since the say the last pandemic the
influenza pandemic is out of 1918
we see that there's this exponential
rise in their discovery
and the slide above shows is a borrowed
from Dr fauci in which he put these
emerging and re-emerging pathogens on
this map every year that he was he's the
director of the National Institute of
biology infectious diseases
and it becomes overwhelming there's no
way to really address all of these
um because what if you try to do that
you're really addressing none of them
so the next
curve is I think a way that we can get
our heads wrapped around us that those
virus species
root into about two dozen virus families
that are particular relevance to human
disease and so if we see
MERS SARS SARS to our future coronavirus
they're all within the virus family
they're cousins of each other they have
common features common traits that we
can focus on common vulnerability so
that we're not developing a vaccine for
Coronavirus X or chronovirus why we're
developing a vaccine for the coronavirus
family
and we can take that approach and apply
it to different
virus families just as we would for the
coronavirus family and so coronaviruses
have been a growing family for us as
humans in as we've learned about them
and and the real major concern has been
beta coronaviruses and that's where
Stars won
SARS to and MERS come from they come
from this one genus within the
carnivorous family
so there are different approaches to
making vaccines and we've seen the whole
extent of this over
the past two years of some old platforms
and new approaches
and
um I just wanted to First provide this
site to provide some context into which
category our vaccine falls into and it's
on the right side it's a recombinant
protein vaccine
um
and that is a little bit different than
some of the others out there because
it's a nanoparticle approach But
ultimately it's a protein that is
coupled with something called an
adjuvant which is sort of a chemical
um mediator to enhance or boost
the immune response along with the
protein
um
but how is it a little bit different
well first things first is that we along
with others
and rooted in the work that myself and
my conventor Dr Gordon Joyce had done at
the vaccine Research Center which was
responsible for engineering the version
of the vaccine that is in all all the
different platforms that are used in the
US
we take a structure-based approach
meaning
we learn the atomic level
topography and geography of the proteins
on the surface of these viruses
we get a 3D map a GPS essentially of the
proteins that
elicits immunity and in the context of
SARS cov2 that is the spike protein that
protein that mediates attachments of the
virus and fusion of the virus with
yourself particularly your lung cells
um and then we use these maps to design
vaccines and Therapeutics
but it's an iterative cycle and so we
sort of modify and optimize the
engineering of these proteins and see
how they do in animals and if they don't
do great then we optimize it some more
so
that was really a major part of the
development of these vaccines but all
this happened years before the pandemic
occurred so that when the pandemic
emerged we were ready in many ways
foreign so we think the structures
matter
and a lot of this work was done in the
context of another respiratory virus
respiratory and social bars but also on
the top middle here you see that uh
little soccer ball uh like image
that is the platform in which we deliver
the structurally modified antigen
um and you can deliver these antigens in
different ways
um mRNA
virus vectors
and we're taking the approach of a
nanoparticle a scaffold essentially
on which we put the spike protein and
in this case we're using ferritin
let me get into what
exactly ferritin is so I'll talk a few
minutes about the design of our vaccine
um we do from very early on really from
the first day that we wanted to take a
long-term broad approach to this
coronavirus as we have been trying to do
that in the context of other virus
families as well before the pandemic
um so January of 2020 we started taking
approach to develop a more Universal
approach to chronovirus vaccines in
January 2022 Dr fauci and others
um
really made the case that we do in fact
need more Universal approaches to
chronovirus coronaviruses
and this was really in the wake of of
all macron emerging
and at a White House briefing on the
same day he highlighted several
different promising approaches one of
which was ours in the right upper hand
corner
and the idea is that and they're all
nanoparticle approaches why isn't that a
particle uh a potentially good option
well you can potentially you can put
different
antigens different spikes in this case
um or different parts of the spike
um on a single particle
that single particle then interacts with
a B cell b cells are the cells that
generate antibodies
well if there uh a single B cell is
interacting with two different spikes at
the same time first of all it's giving
it you know a boost in terms of the
signals to produce antibodies but also
what it's going to do is it's going to
focus on those common areas between the
two different antigens and develop
antibodies against conserved parts of
those antigens and so that you get
antibodies that are more broadly active
so we there are different nanoparticles
that you can use uh leechotes ferritin
as ours for several reasons
ferriting is ubiquitous in
um across life in animals plants
bacteria and so we use a ferritin from a
bacterium H pylori which can cause
gastric ulcers
because we wanted to choose something
that was very far from Human character
because if you develop any antibodies
against the ferritin part
that could be problematic if it's
developing antibodies against human
character ferritin is very important in
carrying iron which is important in
your synthesis with blood and carrying
oxygen around
so we don't want people to develop
antibiotics against ferritin where it
could cause a severe anemia
so
um we chose ferritin uh one because
um
it's it's
ubiquitous relatively available and you
know and and we have options to use
versions that are very far from Human
two is that Sheraton has some
interesting geometry
um it
when you express ferritin it actually
polymerizes on its own into this 24
uh component cage
um and when all these 24 ferritants come
together in this
polymer cage they form this act this um
Symmetry and it's a three-fold symmetry
at these different juncture points
that's important because
proteins like the spike protein and many
other proteins that are important for
Fusion of viruses with human cells have
a threefold symmetry
so the spike protein in nature on
viruses is not just a single Spike
protein it's a triplet it's like a
little bouquet of three spikes
wrapped around each other so if you want
to present these Spike proteins in the
conformation that they occur in nature
on the surface of viruses we need
something that will present it in that
triplet form and you need that
three-fold Symmetry and that's what
ferritin has
another reason why we chose ferritin is
because we had worked with it at the
vaccine Research Center at the NIH in
the context of the universal food
vaccine program
and this part this particle for flu had
already gone into clinical trials and so
we had some safety data for ferritin
that we could cross-reference when we
took our vaccine for covet into clinical
trials
and you essentially can link whatever
you want you have to do some
modifications in engineering but you can
link whatever you want to that ferritin
in this case we use
either the spike or some
um component of the spike and it
decorates on its own assembles and then
now you have
decorating the surface of the scaffold
ferritin all around
your antigen of joints
so we went through a
extensive
but accelerated design cycle in which we
developed 215 different candidates in
the course of two months
and
tested them about 2 000 mice and we came
up with four different categories of
ferritin nanoparticles uh up on the left
hand corner is a model of a structural
model of the spike ferritin nanoparticle
down at the bottom
is a receptor binding domain uh
serotoninoparticle and then the two
right hand ones are versions of that
that container structure binding domain
but are a little bit larger the S1
subunit but are not the entire Spike
protein ultimately
through all the mouse experiments we did
we found that the spike therapy
nanoparticle was really the best
um option best version and we use the
pre-fusion stabilized version that was
developed at the NIH and it's used in
all the vaccine in use in the United
States
so we went through
a series of optimization
Cycles we had to make modifications to
the base of that Spike protein in the
hinged regions
in order to ensure stable
um and and and uh natural presentation
of the spike protein on the surface of
the ferritin
and then we couple this with an adjuvant
um that chemical booster I was talking
about that had been developed in the
context of the HIV program at our
Institute called alphew Army liposomal
formulation with
um a saponin he was 21.
um that is in at least one other vaccine
in the Nova back vaccine at least a
version of that
um
um not Alpha queue in particular ask you
um is only being used in our vaccine
and here is a electron microscopy image
that shows
the the particle and so we call it
spiffin Spike ferritin nanoparticle so
spiffin
um nanoparticle along with these
globular
um
uh images that represent the
adjectives
so um I'll go through some of the
pre-clinical data
um pretty quickly here because I want to
have time for questions but this can all
be summarized
um at least initially
in this slide in which we
um
we tested our vaccine in mice and
hamsters
between monkeys
um
and in um honest actually in in an
additional species as well and horses
and sharks
um I can answer questions about why we
did those other species too but
the
pattern that kept recurring was that
this was a very potent
vaccine it elicited a very potent
neutralizing antibodies
um and very broadly neutralizing
antibodies against multiple
variants of star scoping 2 and even
other SARS like viruses
um and so for our mouth studies we saw
neutralizing antibodies titers that were
um on the level of ten thousand to a
hundred thousand inhibitory dose at 50
percent
um when we took antibodies
to purify them from the mice that were
vaccinated and then transferred them
into other mice okay 18 mice transgenic
mice and then challenge them with SARS
to we saw
the top uh green and red lines are
superimposed they these animals were
completely protected they all survived
and then we as we brought down the dose
of the antibodies predictably the
survival went down as well
uh we then tested our vaccine in
hamsters and we we tested it against the
alpha and beta strains of sarasco V2
after two immunizations
again like the mice we saw a very high
antibody responses although these are
all binding data not neutralizing data
what we saw was
that those animals those hamsters and
hamsters are a good model we found
um the whole field found in the context
that starts 32 there they
they show uh considerable weight loss
and lung pathology
um at least for all the variants
previous to Omicron
but whether they were challenged with
alpha or beta
those animals that were vaccinated
either with a high dose or even a low
dose of the vaccine twice were very well
protected compared to those that were
not vaccinated
um essentially no virus or very little
virus found in the lungs of vaccinated
animals
um or
um very little virus and the
um upper Airways the nasal turbinates of
these animals that were vaccinated
we looked at
um two different species of monkeys this
represents just one of those experiments
um and what we found in the fields over
the past couple years is that
what you see in monkeys is not always
the case for emerging viruses but in
this case what you see in monkeys is
predictive of what you would see in
humans in terms of vaccine efficacy
and uh we saw again very high
neutralizing antibody responses against
the uh wild-type version the original
Wuhan one string
um
we saw a very strong th1 or CD4 T Cell
responses and engaged memory responses
so we were triggering uh at least again
from the outset memory and T Cell
responses and b-cell responses
and uh we were seeing very precipit
um a rapid
um protection
against challenge in either the lower
Airways from bronchial alveolar lavage
on the left part of the side or in the
upper Airways from nasopharyngeal swaps
on the right side
it was also unique about
our study is that we had a very potent
stock of virus that we were challenging
with uh you can see uh in the left of
each graph in the black that's the
animals that were not vaccinated so
those are the controls
to see what would happen if you weren't
vaccinated
what were the levels of virus in those
animals and they got very very high in
the upper and lower Airways in the upper
Airways around you know 10 million
copies
um per milliliter which is much higher
than all the other studies that had been
done with other vaccines today and
despite that very rigorous challenge
uh with 50 micrograms two doses we saw a
very rapid almost
sterilizing community
um and this wore out in the pathology as
well if animals were vaccinated with 60
micrograms which then twice
essentially were protected from any lung
pathology as well
and there was really no presence of
virus in the longer vaccinated animals
as compared to
the controls as measured by aiming a
physical chemistry
so the other thing we wanted to look at
was the breadth of response and so we
started out looking at the response of
the
elicited by the vaccines in terms of
neutralizing antibodies Against the Wild
type fires Washington Juan and then
again it's Alpha Beta Gamma Delta and we
saw that there wasn't much of a drop
in antibody response when we looked
across the different variants and here
in this slide you can see whether we
look by authentic virus
in these monkeys who've got either 65
um
50 or 5 micrograms of our vaccine twice
or 50 micrograms once or looking by
pseudovirus neutralizing acid one you'll
see that there's just very high
neutralizing antibody responses to begin
with
but if you look all the way to the right
in that id50 GMT full of change
so what we're looking at is the fold
reduction or increase in neutralizing
antibody response against the variance
compared to the original Washington one
string
and if you look just at the top slide
here I mean the top row 50 micrograms
two doses by authentic virus you see
um actually a better response against
the alpha but then not really much of a
reduction in response against beta Gamma
or Delta
um
and actually not even
sorry I pressed here it is you can see
here
um not much of a reduction in response
against those variants compared to the
wild type
so you're getting just as good a
response as the variance as you are
against the original string
um and
we did it separate experiment
um separating our vaccine first dose and
second dose by two months rather than
one month and we challenge with Omicron
and we saw very good responses against
Omicron as well
which is not being seen with a lot of
other vaccines and so we saw responses
um with that 50 micrograms that were
nearing for close to 10 000 again
um and
we also saw that there was a response
against other cervical viruses
so at the top here you see these
different colored bubbles this is the
different Clays of
uh on the phylogenetic tree of the
cervical viruses the sars-like viruses
and sars2 is in that that light blue
clay 1B
uh Stars one is in clay 1A and we're
getting very good responses against both
of those but we're also getting
responses against Place three and Clay
2. these are binding antibody responses
by something called bilayer
intracrometry or we you just call it
octet by short and
and this has been very predictive of
neutralizing antivirus responses as well
we're developing those uh those viruses
now
for uh or testing against some of those
viruses neutralizing assays but just by
binding we're seeing a good response as
well against a broader panel to start
with the viruses
and when we challenge with Omicron from
that monkey study I was referring to
um again we see very good neutralizing
antibody responses after two doses just
before challenge so week 12 and then
when we challenge with Omicron this is
the ba1
subvariant of Omicron and not ba2 or any
of the others we see a very rapid
protection in the animals that got
expecting compared to those that didn't
get vaccinated in either the lower
Airways in the top here Bal or in the
nasal spots in the pot
so
um
we are now completing our first phase
one uh clinical trial with our vaccine
um
and the design is dose escalating we
vaccinated individuals either with 25
micrograms or 50 micrograms
of our vaccine at zero
in one month
um and then there was an option of
getting a six-month vaccination as well
a subset of individuals did get
a six-month vaccination the second group
was a 50 microgram arm
um and
unfortunately we were trying to
um get the trial started quickly but it
didn't start until April 6th of 2021 so
people had started getting vaccinated
and we were enrolling individuals who
were naive to vaccination or infection
so it became difficult to enroll pretty
quickly as vaccinations rolled out
um but we
um we still got
um a uh enough participant to assess
safety and image and it's your
tolerability in Indonesian the city
um and now are analyzing those data and
they look very promising
uh in recapitulating what we saw in the
animals and hopefully I will be able to
present those data publicly in the next
few weeks
and what I'll be presenting is
um pseudovirus neutralizing antibody
titers
um not only against the original strain
but all the variance of concern through
day 209 so all the way through seven
months after initial vaccination binding
antibodies cell mediated immunity
and then looking at breath as well so
broader cervical virus virus
neutralizing antibodies
broader suit of our broader cervical
virus binding antibodies and then we
also have a experiment that we're doing
in which we're taking
antibodies purified IGG from vaccinated
individuals and then transferring them
into hamsters
and then challenging those hamsters
either with Omicron or SARS one
to see if the antibodies elicited by our
vaccine are protective it's a sort of a
surrogate way of assessing efficacy
since we can't really do that in the
context of a clinical trial a baseball
clinical trial
so what's next
um we're going to be looking at
nanoparticle combinations we've already
started doing that we're combining
um Spike character nanoparticles from
Stars 2 with those four stars one or
other coronaviruses which have started
making those as well we've already seen
that cocktails of these vaccines
elicit very potent neutralizing antibody
response again multiple stars like
viruses
um developing more Mosaic antigens so
not just not cocktails but the single
particles that present multiple spikes
on the same particle
and then looking at this with adjuvants
or not with adroitness and looking with
different platforms
looking at expressing our construct our
sequence for nanoparticle in the from
mRNA so
marrying the benefits of mRNA platforms
with nanoparticle platform
thank you
so
I hope that I've given you a little bit
of a flavor into
the general approach and our specific
approach towards developing broadly
active
platforms against coronaviruses that can
then be translated to other virus
families
and
um
that now we're getting into a phase of
this pandemic that hopefully is becoming
more of an endemic disease and now we
can start preparing for future threats
uh and I'll leave you with a quote since
I started you with the quote and this is
a little bit philosophical from uh the
Danish philosopher starting circuit
guard
um in which he said
life can only be understood backwards
but it must be looked forwards and the
meaning of that in the context of the
pandemic is that yes we have to
look back be introspective retrospective
try to understand what we could have
done better but we have to have to have
to apply that going forward I think a
lot of times
when things fade we tend to forget we
tend to divest and now is the time where
we need to invest more than ever in
these kinds of platforms for the future
so that the next time something emerges
a potential pandemic
we actually have a vaccines on the
shelves that have already been tested in
humans that we can start to point right
away and don't even have to wait a year
to have to save millions of lives
thanks for your attention
and I'm happy to take questions
and thank you Dr majered for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of this
webinar and if you have any questions
you want to ask do so now but just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen so let's get
started it looks like we already have a
great set of questions coming in
our first question
as compared to the whole pathogen
vaccine platform a protein subunit
vaccine what are its potentials for a
global covid vaccine
um thanks for that question so I'm
assuming that the the reference to the
whole passage in vaccine platform are
being activated pulling activated virus
vaccine
um which have not shown to be as
effective
either Against the Wild type or against
variants of concern
and largely because uh we think that the
the spike protein on the surface of
those inactivated viruses are in this
close Fusion State and the post Fusion
epitopes that are presented
don't aren't as immunogenic as the
prefusion stabilized version we saw this
in the context of RSV as well and now we
can encounter the coronaviruses too
um
so we are taking the approach of protein
subunits um so either the spike protein
uh which is the whole protein or a
subunit uh either the S1 or really where
a lot of the focus has been on the
receptor binding domain that very
specific part of the spike protein that
interacts with the dehumanase2 receptor
the benefit of rbds as well is that they
don't have to be presented in that
triplet or Primera conformation they can
be monomers
um and that gives you a lot more
flexibility when it comes to developing
Mosaic uh particles where you can have
rbds from multiple different viruses and
you can have more of them on a single
particle and so that definitely is one
of the approaches that we're taking now
the groups are taking as well
cool platforms manufacturing challenges
related to particle heterogeneity
improper folding of fused antigens and
antigen interference with inter-subunit
interactions still need to be overcome
what are your thoughts on that
yeah manufacturing so the the CMC issues
are an important uh aspect of and I
appreciate that question something that
is being thought through
on a global level
um you know within the federal
government
um by The Who by organizations like sepi
the Coalition for epidemic preparedness
innovation
um some of this has it you know we're
we're also kind of borrowing from the
work that's been done in the context of
the flu program as well and interactions
with the FDA
um to develop
um validation processes
um that give an indication of how much
of each antigen is
um is present and is being presented in
your vaccine formulation
um in your in your drug product
um and ensuring that you can
um predictably and consistently quantify
that from Lock to lock
um as you manufacture this product
and on a small scale it's worked very
well uh we've been able to do that we've
been able to demonstrate anagenic
Integrity nanoparticle Integrity
consistency every nanoparticle pretty
much is you know presenting the same
thing same managing in the same ordered
array
but when we get to scaling
um that's that's the the a big issue
other groups there's one other group
that has had some of this issue in terms
of scaling
um so
we'll have to work on on those processes
as we you know trying to move from
making thousands of doses to billions of
justice and that was an issue also for
even backing uh for other Platforms in
the context of this uh pandemic that
well not just the kind of person
thank you so much Dr majard and I want
to thank our audience for these great
questions coming in this is awesome
our next question a major challenge of
ferritin-based vaccines will likely be
related to antigen design example
whether its structure can be maintained
and or it's capable of inducing immune
response after conjunction to the
ferritin any advice about this
um
yeah so
we found that uh that at least for for
for flu uh first of all uh for
coronaviruses and we've been doing work
a lot on Arena viruses as well uh with
uh the GPC protein
that
um we actually get very
um
consistent uh presentation of the Native
confirmation of these constant Fusion
proteins on ferritin
um ferritin is a much smaller
nanoparticle
than other nanoparticles out there which
have some benefits and drawbacks so I
think there was some questions the
previous question asked about sort of
maybe some interference
um if the
the sort of the business and the most
important parts uh immunogenically
immunologically is at the head of the
protein that where we want to induce a
response against like the RVD and it's
not so much of a problem with ferritin
and its size but if it's sort of getting
towards some of the sides or if you want
to get better responses against sort of
the stem or the conscious Converses the
S2 subunit then it becomes a little bit
more difficult for the B cell receptors
to access some of those episodes from
the context of ferritin as opposed to
some other nanoparticles that are being
developed but in terms of the structures
um of the proteins that have been
expressed on the surface of these
serotoninoparticles we've seen a very
good expression uh in in the
confirmation that we uh wanted to be
presented in
um so far uh it does take some
um some additional so it's not just a
matter of taking STP or redeem just
plopping it on there is additional
design that has to go into this uh you
know I showed for
um for a spike ferret and we had to make
some modifications to the hinge region
of what was already modified with the
s2p
and then with RBD we not only had to
kind of play around with the part of the
RBC that was
that was
proximal to the to the six amino acid
blinker we'd also had to modify our
ferritin so our RBD ferritin
nanoparticle is actually a hybrid
or a chimera of
frog ferritin and H pylori ferritin
because with a trilary ferritin we just
couldn't get
the RBD presented in a full nanoparticle
to to form so there is still quite a bit
of playing around with the design that's
why we need to do these things now
it before the pandemics occur because
every day in the context of the pandemic
is very very precious whereas if we're
in an inter-pandemic period we can do we
have a little bit more flexibility in in
taking a little bit longer in optimizing
this design
thank you so much
one of the most prominent futures of
mRNA vaccine is no real memory and no
adaptive Evolution isn't it time to say
that mRNA vaccine isn't qualified to be
a vaccine and the second part of that
maybe is just that it should be another
class of antibody based drugs but not
actually called a vaccine
what else there's still debate about
that in terms of how much a memory mRNA
vaccines uh induce
um because we do see that there is
um both tesol and b-cell memory
um they may not protect
um
so well against
and remember
um
right now so all these mRNA vaccines are
based on the Wuhan one or Washington 1st
strain
and and we're looking at the efficacy
against Omicron which is
you know almost like a very close to
being a different species of Coronavirus
and so
um one issue is sort of the breadth of
response that you're getting
and then the second issue yes is is the
memory but there is definitely memory in
terms of
um the protection against the death and
severe disease against infection alone
uh it's not only necessarily systemic
memory response but the issue that is a
problematic for all of the vaccines in
mucosal response as well to prevent
replication particularly with Omicron
and the upper Airways so I think that's
problematic for all the vaccines
um and mRNA vaccines
are in their adolescence they're no
longer in their infancy but they're not
fully mature platform this is the first
time that they've hit the prime time and
so there's still quite a bit of
optimization that has to take place
there are definitely some disadvantages
that the MRNA platform it is not a
Panacea
but there are some clear advantages
um in terms of scalability first and
foremost for mRNA platforms but they do
need to be optimized better not only the
mrnas but the lipid nanoparticle
formulations in which they come in which
they're packaged to elicit broader and
more durable responses
thank you so much Dr Jared and I want to
thank our audience do you want to
provide any closing remarks before we go
um well first and foremost uh thanks
again uh to you uh Suzy and to the
organizers and for labyrates for giving
me this uh form and this opportunity to
engage with the audience thanks to
everybody for their questions
um I'm happy to have follow-on
discussions uh afterwards of the
organizers have my email
um and
um I hope this was informative and give
you some insights into where the field
is headed we're not the only group doing
this but we're part of a small group The
and growing group that has been looking
at broadly protective approaches to
emerging viruses in general not just
coronaviruses and how we need to do
business differently we don't need to
come back to normal we need to come back
to a new normal and how we anticipate
and prepare for future pandemic
absolutely and Dr majered thank you
again for your time and for your
important research and before we go I
want to thank our audience and their
inch for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand for two
years up to May 4th 2024 Labyrinth will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time stay safe everyone take care
bye-bye thank you